[Music]
foreign
what is older Nancy Pelosi or the
microwave oven
I think I'm sitting here with three
heterosexuals as far as I know there was
something visually interesting about
that the Barbie Premiere in Spain look
what's oh God yes Queen oh my God yes
just yesterday in the State of Florida
they decided middle school students will
be taught that enslaved people benefited
from slavery I feel like they didn't
talk to any African-Americans because we
could have told them I don't know what
the high hell you're talking about
because two of the scholars that were on
the board who put this whole curriculum
together are black he has done literally
everything that anyone right-leaning
could believe in he's he's America's
greatest Governor I've said that and
right now the Rubicon has been crossed
where they think the Santa is going to
betray I'm not even saying that's fair
maybe this is why Trump should stop
lying about DeSantis every which way and
you know he is is there anything you
guys want to tell me about your
sexuality real quick anyone we're good
we're good
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's July 26 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals if you like
that little previously on the Reuben
report uh Brock put that together for us
yesterday we are going to be laying
those out every day come the fall I just
finished watching secession I know I'm
like a year behind everybody or six
months behind everybody basically just
finished watching and you know when you
watch all these drama shows they give
you that little previously on what you
missed recapping and I was like why
don't we do that we have a show we're
guys like us so we threw that thing
together I thought it was fun and we're
gonna keep tweaking those and making
them silly and fun and all that good
stuff guys as you know tomorrow today
Wednesday what day is it Jesus
this year tomorrow is our last day on
the grid until August 23rd we're doing
our big sort of half plus year wrap-up
show tomorrow then I disappear till the
Republican debate August 23rd in
Milwaukee we'll be back I've got santis
on that show Mickey Haley's committed I
think the vet committed Francis Suarez
if he makes it to the debate we're
working on everybody it's going to be a
big big event there rumble's putting
together
a huge stage I think there's gonna be
hundreds of people in the crowd live
streaming it gonna be awesome blah blah
blah as you know we have a post game
show as always at
reubenreport.locals.com and I am super
psyched for today's show I enjoy what I
do for a living but today I feel like we
can sort of birth a new alliance because
I sense something is forming it's
something that we hit on uh mostly on
Monday and then touched on a bit
yesterday but some of you that have been
watching me for a long time you remember
the phrase I have not said it in a
couple years the intellectual dark web
this was a group of people uh sort of
when I was kind of getting popular way
back when when I was one of the first
sort of outside of mainstream people
building a studio in my garage sitting
down with people across the political
divide whether they were Sam Harris on
the left uh or Ben Shapiro on the right
just talking it out having debates about
God and having debates about the role of
government all of these things the thing
kind of blew up this was obviously
related to Joe Rogan as well and a whole
bunch of people but it was it was the
point of it was we were going to defend
free speech and we were going to try to
get over some of the right verse left
Insanity I sense it's reforming it's
retaking shape it's not for me to coin
the new term let's say the new
intellectual dark web we could probably
Eric Weinstein actually came up with
that and it was a little bit sort of
tongue-in-cheek it's not for me to coin
it's probably for one of you guys to
coin what this new thing is but this
thing where Russell Brand is talking to
DeSantis and Tucker Carlson is talking
to Ice Cube and Bill Maher is talking to
Jordan Peterson
etc
etc it's starting to take form and take
shape and it's bigger than politics and
that latest and jelly spoons is the
theme of today's show so let's dive
right into it uh Tucker Carlson who as
you know no longer with Fox he's doing
his solo thing unclear where he will
fully end up he's put putting them on
Twitter for now sounds like he might be
building some sort of media Empire we
shall see he sat down or in a car he
took a drive with Ice Cube rapper Ice
Cube this is the crossover you did not
expect and they drove through South
Central L.A and talked about a bit of
everything here are Tucker and Ice Cube
talking about why Ice Cube did not get
the vaccine
why wouldn't you take the backs
um you had a direct order to take it you
were told to take it yeah I'm not real
good with direct orders but on a whole
nother note
[Music]
but it was a command I didn't I mean
they told I'm sorry they told you I mean
they couldn't have been clearer about it
it was pretty clear
[Music]
did you take it of course not yeah no it
wasn't ready you know it was
six month you know kind of rush job and
and I didn't feel safe
but they told you you were safe I know
what they said
I know what they said and I heard them I
heard them loud and clear
but it's it's not their decision there's
no repercussions if they're wrong but I
get all the repercussions if they're
wrong
was it a tough call for you no it wasn't
a tough call you know I wanted to be an
example for my kids you know really make
sure they didn't take it either
show them that I you know I wanted to
stand on my convictions and that I was
willing
you know to lose nine million dollars
and more because we've probably lost
more
since then
okay so unvaxed Ice Cube in a car
driving through South Central L.A with
unvaxed Tucker Crossing now Tucker
Carlson we didn't know he was on vacs
until a week and a half ago or so when
he did that Blaze forum and ASA
Hutchinson tried to turn the question on
him and then he announced he was unvaxed
uh this isn't specifically about the vax
although it's interesting now to find
out that there were a whole bunch of
people who privately uh weren't getting
vaxed some people did it a little bit
more publicly whatever it might be but
the bigger idea that people weren't just
swallowing The Narrative that people
were saying oh the machine wants us to
do this and it wants to put mandates
down and it used two weeks ago was
saying my body my choice now wants you
to force it wants to force you to do
things and it wants you just because you
work for somebody that that person
should be able to force you to be
injected all that stuff and a lot of
people got red pilled because of it now
I have no doubt that Tucker Carlson and
Ice Cube probably have wide wide
disagreements perhaps on abortion and
borders and all sorts of political stuff
but this goes to the new thing that is
is taking shape right in front of us and
I think that all of us that care about
freedom and free speech and decency and
living in a country with people that are
different from us and all of that stuff
we can help shape it right now right we
can be the people with the clay that are
doing the thing and that would be pretty
good okay so if they're sort of on that
same team what is that same team it
seems to be somewhat pro-truth right it
doesn't just swallow what the narrative
is it's definitely somewhat anti-woke my
guess is Ice Cube's got some woke stuff
within them but it's it's more
anti-machine it's showing you that
politics is not the end-all be-all uh
let's go a little bit further on that
interview uh Ice Cube talks about how he
was painted the villain for taking a
stand on this stuff
the idea is that people who stand on
their convictions are heroes they're
Brave they have principles
you know they're the people we look to
for inspiration but in this case with
this decision and these principles
you were not hailed as a hero
no
we were attacked
so why won't you get the vaccine man hey
look man I'd just rather be myself then
take that vaccine like you other three
billion boat jokes I've never told
anyone not to get vaccinated publicly
that was never my message to the world
I didn't even want people to know
whether I got vaccinated or not I was
pretty upset that that even came out
because
I was just gonna quietly
you know
not take it and
deal with the consequences as they came
do you know anyone who was injured by
the vaccine I do
and they suffer every day and it's
it's hard to watch
suffering in silence is not the answer
all the time
you know sometimes you gotta let people
know what's going on so you can actually
move the needle choose to be vocal if
it's true why can't I say it
well you can't say it because it is true
ah there it is now that's the problem
with the world today
there's no penalty for lying no one's
ever punished for lying it's only
telling the truth it gets you in trouble
ain't that something that's true yeah
that is so true okay so that's it again
there's just no doubt these guys have
major political differences I've got
some political differences with Tucker
and I have again no doubt that I have
political disagreements whatever it
might be with Ice Cube it doesn't matter
there's a bigger thing happening right
now and you know the way the best
example that I can give you which is
what they gave you right there when you
talk about the machines okay well what
is the machine it's this amorphous thing
the machine is Saturday Night Live that
clip they showed you where that hack
comedian is doing an impression of Ice
Cube and making it look like Ice Cube
because he was skeptical of a vaccine
that in the earlier clip they talked
about how it was rushed through in six
months which by the way I think that's
partly why Trump didn't show up to that
Blaze media thing with Tucker because
Tucker would hit him on that right Trump
is still very very proud of operation
warp speed but the point is what is the
machine the machine is the corporate
press and the corporate comedy that when
someone dare takes a step against it
they mock the hell out of you and they
try to turn you into the bad guy but now
there is this Bizarro New Alliance so
I'm going to show you something from Fox
News that's going to be a bit odd
because Fox News is platforming a
Democratic candidate unlike MSNBC and
unlike CNN who refuse in Jake tapper's
own words he refuses to have RFK Jr on
well Sean Hannity did a town hall with
RFK Jr yesterday uh here's RFK who again
as he said on my very show just a couple
weeks ago he just wants to have these
conversations he wants to talk about
these difficult things he wants to put a
little sunlight to allow freedom to
spread freedom to grow right that's what
he's trying to do he lays out his
argument or his campaign right here we
have a minute left in this hour
and I want to ask you this
you you're talking to the American
people tonight why should they vote for
you for president
tell them make I mean in a one minute
final statement
I mean you know I'm running on a um
I think most Americans were at each
other's throats today
we have the worst polarization that
we've ever had since the American Civil
War it's more dangerous and more toxic
the 60s is a little crazy too I mean
when my father ran it was you know there
was a lot of uh division at that time
but it's hard to say see how this is
ever going to end well
and what I've said is I want to end that
polarization and I want to do that by
telling the truth
[Applause]
the way that we're going to do that the
first step we have to take it is to tell
the truth of somebody have a president
who's willing to tell the truth about
everything
wouldn't that be something if we had a
president who told the truth think about
our current president who I suppose you
could say is the leader of the machine
or at least the figurehead of the
machine right he's not really leading
this thing he's a cog in the machine he
thinks he's in charge of the machine but
Joe Biden can't say anything true Joe
Biden doesn't know what he's talking
about Joe Biden reads poorly off a
teleprompter or the notes that they put
in front of him we have spokespeople I
cringe on Pierre who lie for a living
they are literally paid to lie we have
people on MSNBC and on The View as I
referenced the other day you know Whoopi
they literally just put a card in front
of her and she just reads it she doesn't
know what she's saying or why she's
saying it and it's not even about uh Joy
Reed or or Rachel Maddow on MSNBC
they're lying of course they're lying
about virtually everything but the
question they're just actors they're
just they're cogs in the machine the
machine works all the way up to much
bigger pieces so it's the producers it's
the executives above them it's the
people above them that's what we're all
trying to figure out and fight and it's
it's not left versus right anymore it's
it's anyone who is roughly sane versus
the obvious liars and dare I say
scumbags so here is a bit that might uh
might shock you because uh most of you
watching this or let's say right leaning
or disaffected liberals probably more on
the conservative side of things
especially when it comes to economics
but here's RFK really making a populist
capitalist argument on economics the guy
running as a Democrat on Fox news for a
conservative crowd
but we don't have free market capitalism
in this country we have corporate
chronic capitalism
[Applause]
we have a system of of cushy socialism
for the super rich and the this uh
brutal
a kind of brutal Savage merciless
capitalism for the poor and it's all
designed to strip mine the middle class
in this country of all of their Equity
all of their assets and move it to the
upper echelons and and you know the
covet lockdowns
with a final straw covered lockdowns we
created a billionaire a day and this was
Trump and Biden of 500 Days of lockdowns
we created a billionaire a day we moved
four trillion dollars from the American
middle class to the super rich we Bill
the people who came into the lockdown
with 30 with a billion dollars increase
their wealth on average by 30 percent
and you can you know we closed 3.3
million businesses
and so that in retrospect and and I give
for a period of time in the early days
nobody knew what the hell they were
dealing with let's be fair but there
came I'm not going to be fair though you
don't be fair
in the early days
I'm not going to be fair it's kind of
beautiful Hannity has to kind of I don't
think Hannity was doing anything on tour
there but you know he's a trump guy so
he has to like kind of like Run cover a
little bit for Trump but in essence what
RFK is saying there is that Trump and
Biden they're part of the machine
they're the ones who locked us down as
uh Tucker and Ice Cube talked about six
months to rush out of Acts that was
Trump Biden was much bigger on lockdowns
and mandates and all of those things
Trump giving fauci an award on his way
out right so what does this all lead us
to like what does it get us to if
there's a whole bunch of people that are
just making some sense right now that
are not radicals we're all going to be
painted as radicals and racists and as I
said Jake Tapper won't have RFK Jr on
Phoenix mentioned to me right before we
started the show that apparently Sam
Harris who was a a big piece of that
intellectual dark web thing that I
mentioned up top apparently on his
podcast this week he just announced that
he would never have Sam have RFK Jr on
like there's somebody
thing happening here so what is it that
we are really fighting well I think RFK
really kind of nailed it right here
and then none of these big tech
companies allowed anybody to read the
laptop story in the weeks leading up to
that election now to me that is our
government in this case through the FBI
putting cinder blocks on a scale of an
election is that something you would
stop and do you agree with me yeah I
would stop that in fact I'm going to
issue an executive award at the moment I
get into the White House the first day
for bidding
of ending the weaponization of our
agencies for political purposes
it's worse than it's ever been my in my
view it's worse than it's ever been and
you know one party will be empowered and
then they'll start doing it to the other
party and of course back and forth all
right so what defines this new please
you name it group
that includes you if you're watching
this this new Coalition this thing
that's trying to take shape it's ending
the machine and the agencies and their
collusion with big Tech and their
assault on the First Amendment their
assault actually on the Second Amendment
their assault
really on all of our foundational
documents and our right to live as we
see fit but this thing it's not just
about I'm giving you some Heavy Hitters
Tucker and RFK Jr and all of this it's
it's actually starting to leak into a
much wider I would say cultural uh
moment on Tim Poole's podcast yesterday
it felt like a Reuben report old school
get-together Roseanne Barr who Roseanne
by the way I've mentioned this before
when I've had her on the show a couple
times and we were we were pretty good
friends when I lived in La for a while
Roseanne who was a lefty her entire life
right the show of Roseanne was about
this blue-collar family that was you
know really just like they were trying
to do things about race on the show the
first ever lesbian kiss if you're into
that sort of thing on network television
was on Roseanne's show Lefty her entire
life then she came out as a trump
supporter machine tries to destroy her
then they bring back you may remember
what was it five years or so ago they
bring back the rose and show it's the
number one sitcom In America she makes
one off-color joke and they cancel the
number one sitcom In America actually
they canceled her they continued the
show and then the show of course without
Roseanne oddly Roseanne without Roseanne
that got canceled immediately after
anyway Roseanne went on Tim Poole's
podcast yesterday uh with Michael malis
who's a many Time guest of the Reuben
report and they started talking about
this divide two and a bit about how we
get past it
oh it's just so scary and horrible I I
just I'm so afraid I just have to say
I'm so afraid what what are you afraid
of what's happening to our country and
how divided we are how we can't get how
we can't get together to make it better
for all of us we just yeah but we'll go
down fighting each other but when the
government owners are getting richer and
uh it's just but but Roseanne look at
her wait when the government gets
together it screws over the middle class
in the favor of people of political
access and power well that's what I'm
saying I'm scared of that now how bad
it's going to get regular people so how
do we know that this cultural crossover
is legit first off you've got like you
know major Hollywood sitcom Stars
sitting down with anarchists at Tim
Poole's House in West Virginia like
something about all of that it's just
like there's something bubbling up I
felt this years ago I'm feeling it again
I know this thing is real but how do we
know that there that it's actually legit
and again I'm going to take that shape
that this isn't just like a little blip
on the internet well you have to look at
how the mainstream media reacts to it so
something very interesting believe it or
not something not just idiotic that
that's every week on The View but
something interesting happened on The
View yesterday corporate machine view
they went after Ben Shapiro yes who is
part of this now you may say Ben is a
little more partisan right uh and that
that probably is right but Ben I think
is a relatively Fair Arbiter of what's
going on in the world and the point is
that he and the daily wire especially
now that Jordan Peterson are there and
everybody else and Knowles and they're
all taken off they are now a threat to
the machine so what does the machine do
it goes after you so here is whoopee
once again who has no idea what she's
talking about going off on Ben Shapiro
because he's critical of the Barbie
movie
I find it upsetting when material is
based on children's IP marketed to
little girls actually ends up being
angry feminist claptrap that alienates
men from women undermines basic human
values and promotes falsehood all at the
same time
wow it's a movie
I I thought y'all would be happy she has
no genitalia so there's no sex involved
Ken has no genitality so he can't be
it's a doll movie
and you know who I
the kids
know it's colorful and it's Barbie they
haven't lived through what the adults
have lived through so when they're
seeing this movie that's not how they're
looking at it the kids are looking at it
there's a Barbie movie you guys I want
you all to tell your daughters why
you're not taking them to see the Barbie
I want you to explain to them what's
wrong with Barbie now look
I love my bar
oh my gosh
it's a dog movie guys that's I'm shocked
that that's what's freaking you out
these days all right first off those
shoes are what's freaking me out but
putting that aside for a second
um they are such deeply if you can be a
deeply shallow thinker that's what these
people are it's not just a doll movie if
you listen to any of the people that
made the movie they're telling you that
they're putting political and cultural
messages in there Brock God bless him he
saw a Barbie he went out there on your
own volition you just he was excited to
see Barbie I sent him out there to find
I send him it's like sending a guy out
to war to find out what's going on in
the real world I'm not gonna do it he
comes back and he reports back to me
when she's saying oh it's just it is
it's just a doll movie it has nothing to
do in the movie according to Brock then
I trust this guy okay uh he says that a
middle schooler in the movie calls
Barbie a fascist so it doesn't even
matter what that's specifically about in
the movie the point is it's not just a
doll movie about a doll with no gen
titles they are pushing we played some
of the the song uh yesterday about it
right we played it at the top of the
show in the cold open like they are
trying to do something by the way as I
said yesterday
they can create whatever the hell they
want to create we can react to it I
would prefer that people just build new
things instead of destroying old things
but that's not really what this is about
what this really is about is that the
machine now is viewing remember remember
it was literally over a year ago
remember that week
where everybody on CNN including several
people who have been fired like Don
Lemon and Brian stelter remember with
that whole week where they kept saying
Joe Rogan is a racist because he said
the n-word several times and shouldn't
Spotify do something about Joe Rogan and
I kept saying it has nothing to do with
them thinking he's a racist nobody in
their right mind thinks Joe Rogan's a
racist what CNN did not want because
it's part of the machine is that an
independent guy sitting in Austin Texas
who's doing Ayahuasca hanging out with
all this eclectic group of people who is
making more sense and getting more
viewers than them so they were trying to
take out the competition I also want to
say one other thing man I'm fired up
today let me say one other thing on this
and then I have a whole bunch of other
things to say so it's not really one
other thing
if I just say one more thing and then
we're ending the show
um when she says uh well I said the
thing about it's just a movie but she
says it's just a doll it's just the doll
and why are we getting worked up over
this lady uh you guys were just
screaming and ranting and raving over
just a song Yesterday just Jason Aldean
right he's a racist everyone involved is
a racist anyway here is total corporate
machine sellout pretend pet conservative
Alyssa Farah with some clap trap enjoy
I also just aspire to have like the time
and energy to get worked up over a doll
movie like it reminds me of the Bud
Light but you know Scandal or whatever
is there not something more important
going on in the world to get super
passionate about but it is to Joy's
point it kind of shows how the right
wing influencers are actually out of
touch with actual Republicans every
girlfriend of mine Republican and
Democrat lined up this weekend to see it
there were memes people were dressing up
to go see it it's fun Greta gerwood's
brilliant but also I'm so taken by some
of these right-wing men who have all
these thoughts on masculinity like
somehow the Barbie movie is going to
make them feel emasculated no caring so
much about it is honestly the most
emasculating thing I could think of oh
you got your talking points lady and you
are giving the machine just what it
wants because you are an ineffectual
pet Republican conservative and they
will all turn on you Alyssa Farah
whatever you're making like you better
be saving that money because they will
all one day turn on you all of your
friends all of those women I hope you
are proud and again I say that not
because I'm making some big brouhaha
over Barbie and whatever the message was
or wasn't in Barbie I'm making the
brouhaha oh for Howie now you can see
the machine operating on people who are
thinking a little bit differently about
things who are thinking a little bit uh
more clearly and more critically about
things so now I want to go old school on
you and some of you who have watched
this show for a while might remember
this clip this is several houses ago
when I lived in that crazy place of what
oh no you let's do something else first
okay we're changing something on the Fly
first before I get to that I want to
show you uh because when Alyssa is
talking about the right wing influencers
online and remember she's corporate
press right
now I want to show you something from
what this has got to be from what 20
years ago at least about 20 years ago
here's Elon Musk 20 years ago predicting
of how Corporate media the mainstream
media whatever you want to call it that
the internet is gonna so fundamentally
change that and how we get information
and that's the tension that I'm talking
about throughout today's episode
I think the internet is the the superset
of all media it is the
it is the the Buell and end-all of of
media one will see print uh broadcast
arguably uh radio
essentially all media
folding into the internet and what the
internet amounts to is it's it's the
first
of uh
two-way communication medium that that
is that is intelligent it allows
consumers to choose what they want to
see when they want to see it and whether
that be radio whether that be print
whether that be television broadcast I
think it's going to revolutionize all
traditional media
first I have to say on like a little bit
of like a personal watching that video
from 1996 right so 25 plus years ago
like the energy of him the
thoughtfulness of him the way he speaks
it's so like the way that I've spent
time with him privately and what you see
of him publicly that he was always
thinking about all of these things to
open up communication and all of this
it's why he bought Twitter all of that
but but you can see he was pointing out
back then that he was basically saying
oh there's this star in the distance and
this star in the distance is the promise
of the internet where all of the things
that we consume will start being opened
up we will have new ways of
communicating new ways of getting
information all of this and it will be
good and and the promise of it the hope
of it I guess the synthwave version of
it was that it was going to be free and
awesome and cool and unfortunately we
found while a lot of that happened right
we we got all these new voices and all
of that my my career literally me
sitting here right now your ability to
watch this on your phone or whatever
you're doing we got a lot of that but it
also came with a crazy amount of
censorship and it came with a crazy
amount of algorithmic manipulation to
divide us and it came with political
polarization and it came with government
censorship with big Tech and everything
else so now I want to do that throwback
clip this is from August of 2018 so this
is five years ago
uh this is me talking with Eric
Weinstein and we were discussing this
was right after Alex Jones was
de-platformed off everything right now
whether you like Alex Jones or don't
like Alex Jones should he be able to
communicate with people is he doing
anything illegal blah blah blah blah
blah I have many times since had a Maya
culpa on this one that I should have
even offered him more of a defense than
I did although I did offer him a bit of
a defense when it was very unpopular to
do so uh anyway uh here is uh Dave Rubin
and Eric Weinstein talking about how the
machine will look to de-platform all of
the people who speak out differently and
do you think that has a little something
to do with what's going on right now
this is just their way of inching us
closer to de-platforming it may be you
think but you think that's a secondary
issue here well what I'm trying to say
is
and by the way thank you for having uh
my friend Peter Thiel on oh yeah no
problem that was great yeah we can talk
about that too um
you know Peter has this This brilliant
way of analyzing things is that you have
something that a powerful entity could
do
uh and then he says but the level of
violence needed to accomplish that goal
is probably not something that that
entity could stomach well I have no
doubt that people are fantasizing about
doing to all of these people what was
done to Alex Jones
right with Alex Jones there's so much
over the top stuff that a lot of people
who
read the Messiah released thank God
somebody rid us of that terrible Alex
Jones now I'm not going to get into
whether Alex Jones is good or bad no no
but putting putting let me continue
slightly
they could try to take the alternative
influence Network that they have
identified off the air
okay what would that look like you've
got to somehow get rid of Joe Rogan
Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro Dave Rubin
Sam Harris
Etc et cetera and we've got new kids
coming up all the time who are said to
be
major voices so are you going to get rid
of all of these people because if you do
that the only way to do that is in such
a visible way that the way they can do
this now is is harassment through
algorithms
okay I think you got the point there and
if you want to check out that full I
think we did like a two hour live stream
uh you can find that online obviously
but the point is it was never going to
stop with Alex Jones and now you can see
you can see the way they treat RFK Jr
who is not allowed on CNN right and
again whether you agree with him on
everything or not whether you think he's
got some conspiracy theories or is mixed
up on this or that or the other thing or
you have political disagreements with
him like I do he clearly is not outside
of the Overton window if you connect
that to then what I was talking about a
moment ago Spotify being pressured to
get rid of Rogan a year ago it had
nothing to do with anyone thinking that
Joe Rogan was racist or anything else
all of the people who were de-platformed
because of vaccines the Canadian
truckers who had their bank accounts
closed all of this stuff I think again
you can see the picture and why I think
this new thing is forming so now let's
jump over over to that Joe Rogan guy
because here he is talking about how the
government is going to go out of its way
to regulate everything there will be new
open source sites there will be sites
built to protect Free Speech but the
government the machine is going to do
everything it down and to clamp down and
we don't know as Eric pointed out we
don't know exactly what that will look
like but I think we're starting to get
some hints
if the open source movement does take
hold if people recognize this as being a
real serious threat and start applying
you know just using whatever it is
whether it's minds or the the various
open source social media networks don't
you think the government would somehow
another try to regulate that as well if
they've already got control over
Facebook and Twitter and well that's the
threat so the the threat always is that
they're going to come in and do that and
that that is what they're threatening to
do that there is energy in Washington by
people trying to figure out how to
regulator ban uh open source
having said that banning open source
like interfering at that level carries
consequences with it and so for example
and there are proposals there are
serious proposals from serious people to
do what I'm about to describe do you run
do you run a software program on
everybody's own computer right watching
everything that they do because you have
to make sure that they're not running
software that's supposed to be running
you know do you have basically an agent
built into everybody's chip so that it's
not running you know software that's not
supposed to be running right and then
what do you do when somebody's running
an approved software you know do you
send somebody to their house to take
their computer away right so I should
have mentioned before the clip the guy
he's talking to there is an internet
Legend in his own right that's Mark
Andreessen who is a billionaire Tech guy
who has done a gajillion a gajillion
site he did pass on locals by the way
but that's okay uh he's a good guy uh
but the point is even as we decentralize
things will the machine try to figure
out how to take us out why is the
machine so against Bitcoin the idea that
I could store a decentralized some
something of value and exchange value
with you in a decentralized way that has
nothing to do with the government why is
that a threat to the government well
then they don't get their peace right
because they're basically like the mafia
at this point so now I want to show you
again how does the machine react when
good people don't do crazy things just
try to think things through properly
just try to question the narrative Etc
well on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC they had a lawyer a
national security analyst and a former
government official former D.C Federal
prosecutor by the name of Mary McCord
and uh she doesn't seem to understand
what the first amendment is enjoy
the intersection of U.S national
security with an orientation toward
threats from abroad where I think I know
from my time in government exactly what
we would do if a foreign terrorist
organization or an American adversary
threatened us what is it that we do when
prominent figures or someone from the
ex-president's cabinet threatens us
all right this is the challenge because
domestically uh Speech is protected by
the First Amendment and that has been
interpreted very very broadly to protect
almost everything that can that you know
including things that can sound pretty
threatening unless they cross over the
line into sort of what's called a true
threat and that means uh the First
Amendment does not protect violence or
incitement to imminent violence but the
line about where that is and when a
threat becomes that type of incitement
to imminent violence or violence itself
is something that the courts have
struggled with over time and I think
that that's been essentially weaponized
by extremists to really push that
envelope and try to stay where they feel
is just on the protected side of the
line
sometimes I admire them like their
ability to sort of sound smart while
saying the most authoritarian evil
imaginable is just incredible yes there
is a line because there are things that
are within the law and not within the
law so there is a line as it relates to
free speech and direct threats uh the
idea that you yell fire with the intent
to do harm in a movie theater there are
things that you cannot cross that then
are are criminal acts libel and slander
again these are very very narrow things
around the first amendment but but you
see what she's saying you see these
right Wingers they're they're
weaponizing First Amendment they're
figuring out ways to get in and out of
those lines they're weaponizing it and
what she really means by right Wingers
is she means anyone who doesn't agree
with her anyone who doesn't agree with
the machine's narrative she's certainly
the I don't know her specifically but
the people who say these things they are
the same people who don't want RFK Jr to
be heard in no Thane way could you
consider him a traditional right winger
so you see what they're doing but it
continues on MSNBC this guy this guy
Paul reichoff founder of righteous media
whatever that is uh he wants more laws
they want he wants the government to
look into you and they're happy to give
him a platform because apparently that's
not radical
what does that look like in action
because I I know you sort of sit at the
the fulcrum of peering over into into
two abysses if you will
um what does that sound like
well I I think that there's a core Point
here which is a lot of Americans are up
for grabs I wouldn't dismiss it as just
something that only people on the right
are watching Fox News can latch on to I
mean we're in a battle for hearts and
minds and there are people who are on
the fence you've got to have leaders and
messages and Messengers and programs
that get to those people that bring them
over into Community organizing and into
non-profit organizations and away from
the Patriot front and The Oath Keepers
and I think the parallels with that
weapons are important we've talked about
this before after 9 11 the laws didn't
work like they made massive changes to
respond to a new threat I think we have
to face the fact that many of our
structures laws and policies may not
work after 9 11 we created the
Department of Homeland Security there
was the Patriot Act there was massive
change in our entire Society to face the
number one threat or at least what was
communicated as a number one threat I
think we need the same kind of tectonic
shift it's got to be much more than see
something say something but maybe our
laws need to change to respond to the
fact that someone like Mike Flynn the
former National Security director is
openly calling for violence consistently
that is one of the most mind-blowingly
self-conflicting statements I've ever
heard he's saying oh the Patriot Act all
of these new laws they didn't work which
is why we need a whole new rehash of all
of these things we just need the machine
to give us new laws now that all of
those laws that the very machine gave us
about a perceived threat much like we
have a perceived threat right now that
didn't work so if we get a whole
bunch new come on
so guys who is holding us back and who
is becoming more like the machine every
single day well I have said for quite
some time that unfortunately it is with
great dismay actually that I say this
but Donald Trump at this point is part
of the machine one of the key facets of
the machine is endlessly lying no matter
what right because the machine wants you
to never know what is true so it can
manipulate you in any way and you know
five or seven years ago when a lot of
people were into the Trump thing and he
was loose with the truth he was he was
being loose with the truth and being
sarcastic and everything because he was
defeating the the he was going after the
swamp in the machine and everything else
now he's using the exact same tactics as
him I want to show you this I know it's
going to piss some of my viewers off and
that's just fine because I have to tell
you the truth so check this out uh this
tweet uh this is a uh well this is a
press release that team Trump put out
yesterday so this is from the Trump make
America great again 20 24 official
campaign Unholy Alliance the santis
campaign colluding with Biden's
weaponized doj to stop president Trump
trump and the Maga movement he is and
then there's this ridiculous statement
in there he is pretending that you
really need to think about this come
back to me for a second before we read
the Tweet
um you really need to think about this
and then I'm going to read a tweet
analyzing it
um the idea that Ron DeSantis who has
done more to fight the woke get ESG out
of our schools you know all the stuff
that he is now working with the Biden
Administration to take out Donald Trump
it is completely made up nonsense but it
is nonsense that Trump is throwing on
his people and as I discussed with
Charlie Kirk the other day Charlie said
to me well they don't really care about
the truth they care if something is
attitudinally right so now I want to
read a Girl by the name of Tracy beans
online she she retweeted the Trump thing
and she I thought she had a good
analysis on this she said this is an
email sent by the Trump team today
reading it you'd think DeSantis is
leading the charge to force more
indictments on Trump and he's a crazy
leftist hell-bent on joining the team
attacking him but if you click the link
in the email to read the piece they use
to craft this you'll see that the only
thing that even references any legal
woes for Trump is in the very last
paragraph and is a quote from from a
donor saying that the more legal woes
may affect the trajectory of the race
which is the fourth screenshot she has
there if this type of misleading
nonsense that made me start it's this
type of misleading nonsense that made me
start looking at everything differently
is there just no way DeSantis could ever
win if there is just no way DeSantis
could ever win why do you have to lie
about him to your supporters so you get
it guys there is literally no evidence
none zero that Ron DeSantis is
coordinating with the Biden Department
of Justice Ron DeSantis the guy who's
getting rid of Soros back DA's in in
cities like Tampa right who has done all
of the things that Trump said he was
going to do and Trump is trying it's
politics Trump is trying to destroy him
in in the name of his quest for power
but
in this new world that I'm trying to lay
out that lying is just as bad as the
other line that's what I'm trying to
show you so I I retweeted it I wrote
this and I think uh I think it captures
it Trump can lie about anything and none
of his supporters or surrogates will say
a word as Charlie Kirk said to me
yesterday it's tonal and attitudinal
they just don't care if he lies about
everything it's a game and he's using
the pawns okay so now let's just jump to
a little bit of my interview with uh
with Charlie now again I am friends with
Charlie I am not placing this out there
to capitals capital letters destroy
Charlie or own Charlie or anything else
but I'm trying to show you that this I
this
this constant lying from the machine
which we now all see in the corporate
press and anything else Trump is just
mirroring it on the other side and we
better find a middle a or we are going
down one way or another so here's me and
Charlie your question is really do you
want to take some of the the anger that
the base has because of the way Trump
being treated at he's being treated
horribly and I completely agree with
that that's right um I agree I agree
there's probably some way to do that but
I would also say to some extent
if you just want to view this in the
political lens maybe this is why Trump
should stop lying about DeSantis every
which way and you know he is everything
he says about DeSantis is a lie
everything he says I'll be honest it's
also a lie when DeSantis goes after
Trump and says he was pro-fauchy and all
that that's just not true but it is
without you in a word on the way we're
out of time Dave Rubin thanks so much
more after the okay you get it he gave
him an award on the way out we have
played the video Trump literally had a
re-election video where it was all fauci
praising Trump they were in bed with
each other they've both said nice things
about each other now you may go who's
covered nobody knew okay fine but stop
lying to me
now but if you only care about tonal and
attitudinal think about the what lies
lies
beget more lies and you think that maybe
that is what has gotten us into this
nonsense so every time someone says the
truth they try to destroy him and that's
why it's so dangerous what Trump is
doing with DeSantis right now forget it
forget if you think DeSantis should be
president or he should stay Governor or
or even if you like the sentence or
anything else this isn't exactly about
DeSantis
everyone that now believes these crazy
theories that Ron DeSantis is now
working with the Department of Justice
to take out Donald Trump has been lied
to by Donald Trump and they seem to want
more and we better think about what that
means before we on on let's say this
side of the political aisle become as
completely batshit bananas as everybody
on the other side you just have to think
about that because I guarantee you I
mean I saw it yesterday on Twitter
nobody nobody on the on the right was
like boy that was a good point uh you
know that we should maybe stop lying
about all of this stuff because it's
dangerous when we find a guy that's
pretty good maybe we like somebody else
we like Trump but we find this guy that
we all loved everybody on the right
universally loved Ron DeSantis and now
Donald Trump has people thinking he is a
turncoat and working with the Biden
Department of Justice it's evil it's
just evil so
what side of this do you want to be on I
think that is the question this is a
good show for me to you know tomorrow's
my last uh show before we go off the
grid and we're going to do kind of a
recap of the last six months and
everything else but I think this is the
theme that I want to take with me as I
go off the grid and I get to think
through some of this stuff and and also
remove some of this stuff from my brain
and come at it with fresh eyes when I
come back but the question is what side
of all of this do you want to be on do
you want to be on the side of the
machine of the deep state of the
corporate press of the Liars of the
people who would gladly inject you and
fire you and close your bank accounts
and call you a racist and all of that
stuff
do you want that the people who will Who
will turn you against people you loved
six months ago for all my trump viewers
my trump supporters who now hate the
Santas like is that the side you want to
be on or do you think it might be a
little bit better to be on the side of
Tucker Carlson of Elon Musk of Russell
Brand of Jordan Peterson of Bill Maher
of Joe Rogan of Brett Weinstein of Glenn
Greenwald of Jay bhattachary of Ron
DeSantis of the all-in podcast guys
David sacks of RFK Jr of Vivek of Ben
Shapiro of ice of ice cube of Eric
Weinstein blah blah blah blah
do you think that that might be the way
out of this thing and that you can
actually you can actually affect its
ability to get us out of the ABY
I think you know what I think and I
leave you with uh well we got one more
clip two of those guys who sat down
earlier in the week we played some of
the clips uh Bill Maher and Jordan
Peterson they disagree on everything
literally the nature of the universe you
have a 67 year old Bachelor lifelong
multi-millionaire atheist versus versus
sitting down with uh the guy who has I
think done more for belief and family
and why you should have children and all
of those things and here they are with
nothing other than mutual respect and
and a joy in sitting with each other and
bridging that divide
yeah I can't tell you how great it is to
have you back well thank you I mean
honestly there was a lot of people who
when you were down and out were very sad
that like oh man that is one guy on the
team and our team is not that big yeah
that we cannot afford to lose you know
so to have you come back and be so on it
and looking good and and funny and you
know Brave as always
man
that is
got it
did I make my case guys
should we have lunch
I think I did guys we have one more show
before I go off the grid that'll be
tomorrow we'll be recapping the last
couple months tell you about a couple
future things coming we're building a
new studio while I'm gone a whole bunch
more we got we got a lot of stuff
cooking for the fall that I'm super
psyched about uh I leave you with a cold
close of Elon breaking down what's going
on over at the new Twitter which is now
known as X apparently although they
haven't fully done it it's a little it's
a little messy actually they tried to
take the freaking sign down and then the
authorities stop them in San Francisco
you can smoke crack on the street and
piss on anybody but I guess taking the
sign down is a bit too much we got a uh
post game show coming up at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 30
seconds thank you for watching and and I
would love to see in the comments of
today's show what is this thing called
I don't think it's the new IDW the new
intellectual dark web but like what is
this thing the one thought that I have
on this and maybe you could take it from
there is that if we're fighting the
machine what fights the machine like
we're all we're all cogs that are trying
to we don't want to be cogs we want to
be something that breaks the machine but
what the hell is it what the hell is it
help me out guys all right see you at
the post game
[Music]
here's Johnny